light right
you
range is go for launch they continue to
monitor the air in the sea space
everything looks good and we finally
have gotten green across the board on
the weather conditions but we can't take
a deep breath quite yet we're gonna have
to watch the weather all the way down to
t0 both here at Kennedy Space Center and
out in the Atlantic in the abort zones
now earlier we saw many of you following
the launch from the United States on our
hotspot map now that we're inside now or
we're seeing large numbers of folks
logging on tuning in from coast to coast
and around the world so we'd like to
know is this your first time watching a
launch live not counting Wednesday and
if not how many of you seen before
tell us using the hashtag launch America
from your favorite social media platform
and with that at t-minus 42 minutes 50
seconds conditions are go and we are
counting down for an on-time launch
let's send it back Kennedy Space Center
as the action begins to pick up on the
pad Dragon SpaceX you are go for Section
seven clothes visors and arm launch
escape system we will but section 7 and
work risers come in close
all right the countdown clock is
continuing to tick my heart is
continuing to beat five million beats a
second and we are getting so so close
right dragon in 7.2 visors are closed
we're arming launch escape system as you
just heard the crew is arming the launch
escape system that is one of the
absolute last big milestones prior to
liftoff
other than nominal Falcon operations
so just a minute ago we saw the crew
access arm retract and obviously we just
heard on the comms Bob and Doug
getting ready to arm the launch escape
system and so that is something that
protects them all the way to orbit so
when when fueling starts at about
t-minus 35 minutes so just over six
minutes from now they will have the
capability to abort to separate from
Falcon nine either on the pad or even
after liftoff that's a critical safety
capability and we are gonna go over to
Hawthorn now to take us through these
next minutes Jesse
we did hear that call out that they are
arming the launch escape system so very
exciting SpaceX has designed a crew
dragon and Falcon nine to be the safest
launches launch system ever flown so we
brought back NIC Picone SpaceX has NIC
the cone to talk more about this again
thanks for coming back and joining us
today Nick hey Jesse happy to be here is
the long range launch here with our
recovery and ground operations teams
awesome and Nicky was our mission
manager for our inflatable tests earlier
this year and now works on the StarLink
team Nick on Wednesday you talked about
the launch escape system could you just
give us a brief summary today for those
that are joining today sure so the
launch escape system again is our
ultimate safety feature to keep Bob and
Doug safe in the event of a major Falcon
anomaly on the pad the system is
designed to automatically fire if
a very exciting day the second attempt
at the launch of the Dragon capsule by a
SpaceX Falcon 9 rocket we started
coverage of this during the week I don't
even I think it was was it Wednesday
Thursday now I don't remember
due to whether the launch was scrubbed
with just 17 minutes remaining
before launch we are now at 39 minutes
remaining and we were just told I have
the wrong thing up on the screen here oh
there we go super chats that was weird
we have just been told that as of about
seven minutes ago the weather is a go
now the launch is in Cape Canaveral
Florida this is an area of the country
that in summer has thunderstorms
frequently so there were thunderstorm
concerns during the week there are
thunderstorm concerns right now the next
launch day if today doesn't happen would
be tomorrow afternoon at a similar time
maybe an hour earlier and there are
thunderstorm concerns then so as of this
morning we were told it's 50/50 seven or
eight minutes ago just before the 45
minute mark
there was a weather is currently a go
communication and that is where we are
right now so I don't know that I guess I
don't know if it's still 50/50 or on the
basis of it being a go at t-minus 45
minutes it means that we are now at 60
70 percent or something like that but so
far we are still on and we may have a
very very exciting and important day in
front of us and I've been looking
forward to this for some time and we
have so much horrible stuff happening on
the planet right now we have so much
horrible stuff happening here in the
United States Donald Trump in the last
couple of hours talking about the you
know looting there will be shooting sort
of thing and that is of course of a
phrase that has horrible white
supremacist history Tom Trump claimed
not to know about it we have incredible
degrees of unrest in dozens of cities
across the country as a result of the
killing by police George Floyd in
Minnesota
the officer Derek shavon has now been
arrested now I'm in a talk
about this on Monday but I want to give
people the right sort of expectations I
don't believe there is going to be a
guilty verdict in the Darracq shavon
there we may not even have a trial but I
don't believe we will get a guilty jury
verdict for Derrick shavon I believe we
will the either see not guilty or we
will see him plead down to something
less serious and the reason why the
reason why is that if you look at the
indictment the indictment already has in
it that the cause of death was a
combination of we'll get back to the
launch momentarily the George Floyd
cause of death according to the autopsy
was a combination of being restrained by
officers pre-existing medical conditions
and possible intoxication so you know
you get a good defense attorney up there
to get a medical examiner and say based
on this soft top see is it likely or put
it is it possible that George Floyd
would have lived had he not been
intoxicated and you will get you know a
medical examiner to go yes absolutely
that is possible that's reasonable doubt
and this is why I am not optimistic that
there are going to be you know if we're
waiting for the big guilty verdict for
Derrick shavon I think is not going to
come more than likely we would see
probably a plea down to you know some
kind of overuse of force or something
like that anyway we're getting ahead of
ourselves but I want people to you know
sort of understand where my head is that
on this and not not the best news then
you've got you know Donald Trump
tweeting I don't know if I even have it
here something about oh here he is
tweeting about the rocket something
about where was this where did he tweet
about vicious dogs from Secret Service I
don't even know let me see if I can find
it dogs
all right must have been before all
right maybe he deleted it or maybe maybe
it was it was further ago in any case
the the gist of what Donald Trump
tweeted was that the most vicious dogs
and bloodthirsty Secret Service agents
are the ones they put at the front lines
if people are looking to protest at the
White House I mean it was just that
ominous
ominous weapons was also said yeah
absolutely sick so we're here for
something that maybe will be a positive
thing I welcome your super chats I
welcome your comments on twitch with
subscriptions I'll be reading them
announcing new members and telling you
about this this mission let's take a
listen to what's going on from Mission
Control
ursin nitrogen tetroxide that's the
oxidizer those two come together and
they ignite in space to propel the
vehicle you don't need that tea tab or a
third thing to ignite because uh
hypergolic propellants don't require it
you just need the fuel and the oxidizer
as you just heard propellant load has
started right so in terms of the
propellant I think what we missed them
saying was that there there are two
propellants that are combined one as I
believe called rp1 the other is liquid
oxygen and these typically at about
right where we are now the 35-minute to
go mark is when they start being loaded
in as we saw during the scrubbed launch
earlier this week if the launch is
scrubbed the astronauts sit in the
capsule during what is at least 40
minutes of unloading the propellant and
everything happens slowly deliberately
every every contingency hopefully every
contingency is accounted for and that's
what we experienced with the launch a
few days ago hopefully a different
outcome today so as a reminder we have
two astronauts who will be propelled by
the Falcon 9 rocket made by Elon Musk's
SpaceX inside of the NASA Dragon space
capsule that as you can see here in this
model sits at the top of the rocket
Douglas Hurley and robert Behnken
scheduled for 322 p.m. Eastern time
meaning about eleven and twenty to
thirty three ish minutes from now and
Donald Trump last week trying to
insinuate himself into the this rocket
launch traveling down to Florida I don't
even know if he's there today I don't
care I'm not commenting I'm not going to
be covering Donald Trump's statement
about this Donald Trump embodies
everything that is the opposite of
science and intellectual curiosity and
joint ventures with other countries etc
etc etc so this is not a trump
event this would be the first launch
from US soil since 2011 this would also
be the first SpaceX crewed mission
spacex of course doing extensive testing
with their Falcon 9 rocket switch
liftoff and then also land it is a
thrust based landing which if we were at
some point to send these to the moon or
to send a people to Mars we would
because of the atmosphere and the lack
of runways we would need a thrust based
landing so the Falcon 9 technology not
only is it more sustainable than simply
jettisoning and losing the rocket it
also is potentially the technology that
would be used if and when humans go to
Mars if there is an abort the the path
the downwind path for this rocket and
Dragon capsule will be sort of a
northeasterly path from Cape Canaveral
where the abort would take place in the
ocean off the coast of North Carolina
roughly and that is where Douglas Hurley
and Robert Benton would be rescued
equipped of course with parachutes is
the Dragon spacecraft and any number any
number from the standpoint of
contingencies they've looked very
strongly at a number of different
contingencies and as far as people are
wondering about the timing and then I'm
gonna get right to these super chats and
and other things we are now at t-minus
31 minutes
launch of course scheduled for zero the
stage 1 Falcon 9 rocket is tentatively
scheduled if everything goes as planned
you the full a stage 1 stage 2 and
capsule would be thrust together at nine
and a half minutes roughly t plus nine
and a half minutes that is when the
stage 1 of the rocket would be already
back down and landing I hope I'm not
getting that wrong that was the
scheduling from from the initial launch
let's take another quick listen to
what's going on of oxygen it gives off a
green colored flame now it's hard to see
on the first stage ignition due to the
water that will be spraying on the pad
but you might just see the green flare
is the second stage engine ignites
following stage separation over two and
a half minutes into flight now currently
first stage fuel tank is about ten
percent full the first stage is a
reminder as you look on the left side of
your screens the first stage is the long
white cylinder at the bottom topped off
by the black cylinder so over two thirds
of the rocket is that first stage so the
fuel tank is getting loaded
we're also loading the liquid oxygen
into so that I think makes sense so if
indeed the first stage separates at
about two minutes in that would suggest
that the nine and nine minute 22 second
time line for that first stage to come
back down and land which is just
unbelievable to see makes a lot of sense
welcome everybody we have something very
exciting potentially we got that a
weather was a go message 17 minutes ago
and we are now thirty minutes from the
possible launch here I want to hear from
you guys questions comments if you're
watching on YouTube send in those super
chats I'm going to read a few right now
then of course we will be thanking
people on twitch a couple of those
people are Justin D winters and vittorio
13 is the desert just subscribed with
twitch prime as well tom Bicknell says I
feel that the lack of convictions for
police officers in these cases is
heavily due to the precedent it would
set i I actually I don't know that I
agree I mean listen that that may see
something that plays into it but there
we have a system that is based on
reasonable doubt and defense attorneys
are very good at creating reasonable
doubt simply because the accused is a
police officer and I talked about that
in a clip earlier this week marina D
says Rogan bases all his arguments on
pure speculation
okay I'm Adam says do you think that the
riots will hurt Biden no Michaela
McGonagall says the one piece of good
news I'm allowing my nerd self to be
excited for I'm also slightly jealous
that there are two astronauts who get to
blast the F out of this country
yes sympathetic to that idea right now
incredible TV says today's word of the
day on dictionary.com is escapism thank
you for providing some for me David as
our country completely collapses God
that I don't believe in help
us all vote him out well said well said
incredible very much appreciate your
support and Joseph Woodward says David
is it possible for you to show us
footage from the live streams protesters
are filming check out única YouTube
channels max chillin and unicorn riot
yeah we could do that this is this is a
stream about something good not
something bad fortunately so maybe we
would look at that a little bit later
but right now the focus is of course the
launch of a SpaceX Falcon 9 rocket with
a dragon a space capsule sitting atop of
it scheduled in just 28 minutes to start
the trajectory of Douglas Hurley and
robert bank and the two astronauts you
see on the right of your screen they're
sort of the middle to the International
Space Station and would be very very
exciting if indeed it happens okay I
believe there oh there's a raid
happening on Twitch like in GTV has
raided with 33 people welcome to all of
you very very exciting day happening
here and very much appreciate your
support
super chats continue to come in
essential says I believe if he's not
charged in Minneapolis will burn the
police officer has has already been I
thought that we got the charges already
didn't we
wasn't it third degree murder maybe I
misread that okay let's take a listen a
little bit more and see what updates we
have it's typically a faster process
both when arriving and leaving but it
does still require pinpoint accuracy to
approach they do once captured a
spacecraft thing gets attached to a
common berthing mechanism same type
report that really so it looks like
they're doing sort of like pre pre
scripted content right now we will
certainly get back to it
53i broses did you see the statement
from st. paul minnesota
Minnesota's mayor this a.m. he claimed
all arrested last night in st. Paul were
from out of the state I didn't see that
but I'm reading a lot about that there
seemed to be I would call him aha well
vaca to write so people sent in to
provoke and we see police participating
in a lot of the instigation we see
listen this is not simple and
there's no way that in a stream about a
launch we are going to be able to fully
cover all elements of this but you know
there's a lot of simplistic hot takes
going around from so-called enlightened
centrists pretending to see both sides
that's not what I do right that's not
that's not my thing so to speak that's
not my gig but there is no doubt that
simply saying once you go to destruction
of property
it is completely you know that it is a
completely unsympathetic action well
that's not true once you say the only
victims here are these people are those
people though that the anything that is
that black and white is not possibly not
possibly going to accurately cover what
it what is going on all right thanks to
Dan we are so pumped right now cuz
things have cleared up and it looks like
we might actually do this today if
you're just joining us we have 25
minutes 46 seconds and counting from the
first launch of astronauts to the
International Space Station from US soil
in nine years this will mark the
beginning of a new era where more people
will be able to fly to space than ever
before and we want to share with you the
results of a poll we asked a little
earlier if you could go to the moon
that's not where the astronauts are
going today they're gonna say it was
good very good
so welcome to everybody flat earthers
included if you are a flat earther then
certainly you must be very excited for
one of the greatest Hollywood
productions in the history of the world
that we are about to see for everybody
else we call this science we call this
reality and it is extraordinarily
exciting and we are going to be finding
out more we are just twenty four minutes
away and as of now the weather looks
pretty pretty solid thank you to Darth
Bane and AD VM for prez all of whom are
supporting me over on Twitch super chats
continuing to come in Victor Carrizo
says very excited saludos the Panama oh
I'll always love to hear from our
Panamanian viewers Scott Phillips says
thanks for giving me a reason to watch
the launch absolutely
we need something like this in our lives
Bernie Sanders says as a professional
magician who's your favorite I have no
idea
Andy Wilcox says what's up with the kid
militia in Atlanta I tweeted about that
it was bizarre if you want to see that
you should be following me on Twitter by
now I did tweet earlier about a supposed
child militia at the Lenox Mall in
Atlanta I don't know what the hell is
going on I don't know what is real at
this point and what is not but this is a
day for positivity so we are standing by
for a very exciting launch also if you
want some positivity I just uploaded
some new elements of gardening to my
Instagram page if you follow me at David
Pakman an inchworm invaded my garden I
picked it up and took a picture with it
very polite inchworm didn't seem
bothered by the photography that's on my
Instagram page I've got an Instagram
story where or actually in my urban
gardening highlights includes I showed
my massive tomatoes I uncovered my
massive Tomatoes and bared all for you
guys yesterday and it I've already got
some huge Tomatoes it's amazing so today
is a day for positive things we've got
the garden we've got hopefully this NASA
SpaceX launch happening momentarily
essential says I wasn't clear if there
is appearance of him getting off lightly
the city will likely burn I understand
okay understood understood
thanks to joker max and jimmy big nuts
for the super chats always very much
appreciate it you know since it's such a
special day today and we have something
so exciting going on I'm gonna tell you
guys a secret we ran a Memorial Day
membership drive on Memorial Day that
was five days ago the coupon code it
still works on my website so even though
we're not promoting it I'm gonna tell
you guys the secret because you're
joining me for such a great event on my
website right now the coupon code
memorial 20 all one word all lowercase
Memorial to zero it is the biggest
membership discount we've ever done and
it's still live on my website so take
advantage of it it's the best way to
support all of the work we do the
political show the political streams the
podcast
YouTube channel twitch livestreams all
of this stuff and the code is Memorial
20 it still works it's a secret but I'm
telling you guys just a few of my
closest friends and everybody who signs
up with that code will get a thank you
from me we are down to under 22 minutes
from the scheduled launch let's take a
listen to whether any news about the
weather although it's looking very nice
right now are a part of our team you
know they're and they're not a customer
they're our team they're not a payload
they're our team they're our family and
so we're just so excited to see the dads
up there today all right we're gonna go
send it over to Gary for an update from
Houston Gary oh hey Murray the Space
Station team here is focused all eyes
are on the system checks that are
happening across the board and we're
listening in as we close in on launch
and I can tell you that things are
looking very good Chris Cassidy will be
watching from the International Space
Station right now flying over the
Pacific Ocean it's heading to cross
right over the launch pad we might even
get some good views from the station
hope to be capturing those we'll have
the launch view in the big screen up
front and everyone's excited to see our
two crew members on their way to the
International Space Station but before
we get to it I just want to pass on good
luck from the entire flight operations
community here in Houston it's always
exciting to be doing something wholly
new and history-making with station
operations and we can't wait to see our
team members Bob and Doug in low-earth
orbit and heading to the International
Space Station that's it from us here in
Mission Control Houston I'll send it
back over to the team in Hawthorne for
the latest happening there John some of
these little segments seemed almost
pre-recorded to make sure that they go
okay but then they're like plate is live
right everything is still looking good
for launch of Falcon 9 and dragon 22
minutes 45 seconds after the hour you
can see a large white cloud coming off
of the strong back that is normal Wow as
we get ready to load the second stage
with liquid oxygen we have to chill in
the plumbing lines going up that strong
back
and so as we relieve pressure the moist
humid Florida air condenses around it
and that gives you the cloud so that
tells us that things are actually on
schedule we did begin propeller load at
t-minus 35 minutes fuel loading on the
second stage I believe we just heard the
call-out that it is complete what a day
what a day ladies and gentlemen and we
are very very much looking forward to
this just under 20 minutes to go at this
point in time and that weather looks
like it's holding out we had a scrubbed
launch earlier this week if today were
to be scrubbed they would try again
tomorrow at 3:00 p.m. Eastern Time and
we will hopefully not need that third
launch window because 19 minutes from
now they may be on the way which would
be just an unbelievable amazing thing
super chats continue to come in a mojo
top Thank You Adrian benningfield says
joke's on you I call it glorified wet
craft David all right very very good
don't totally understand what's going on
there but people clearly extraordinarily
excited by what it is that is going on
here we have the Dragon spacecraft
capsule sitting there at the top of this
two-stage SpaceX rocket as they
mentioned earlier what you're seeing
there below the capsule is the stage two
rocket that is only about a third of the
total length of of the rocket two thirds
of it which are not in in shot right now
are Oh hold on a second I need to adjust
this so everybody can actually see the
countdown there we go what am I do what
a what a savage move there we go
I apologize people weren't able to see
that we are at the 18 minute mark there
as you can see the full rocket this
basically they said that up until this
black section here this is the stage one
rocket this will detach at roughly the T
plus two minute mark there we go that's
a great view this is all stage one that
will detach it roughly two minutes after
takeoff this white section here it's all
equally girthy but this the stage one is
much longer as you can see Stage two
would stay and it is the second stage
and then a
eventually that would separate as well
stage one which is this bottom 2/3 here
is scheduled to land back down on earth
if you can believe it at t plus nine ish
minutes nine minutes and 22 seconds was
the exact scheduled landing time for
that stage one rocket in the first
launch that may have been tweaked a
little bit based on wind and prevailing
weather conditions but we're going to
see absolutely incredible stuff as we
get to so this is the point guys where a
couple of days ago they made the call
that they had to cancel it was at t
minus 17 minutes and we are getting very
very close to that moment right now we
are I so people are asking if I'm going
to be doing coverage of the protests and
uprisings and riots and the like after
this I don't know I don't know we will
let's see how this goes but of course I
am very much aware of everything that is
going on globally and it is scary scary
stuff for sure no no doubt about it but
we're here because this is a positive
thing this is a positive thing let's go
and listen in now that we are closer to
launch than we got a couple of days ago
in free it's about a 19 hour ride if we
launch today on time so that means Bob
and Doug will get on orbit they'll have
a number of burns or those firings of
those Draco thrusters that they'll do
will be to load or we hear the LOX the
liquid oxygen load has now started on
stage two beautiful again they're gonna
be doing a series of burns on the way
uphill towards the International Space
Station five spread out over the the
first 16 hours or so of their flight
until they get much closer and it's time
for that approach and docking and we are
expecting that with an on-time launch to
happen today
that'll be coming tomorrow in the
afternoon
all right now that we're under 16
minutes away we have a special guest
joining us I'm gonna toss it over to
Jesse all right very exciting we are now
under the 16-minute mark people clearly
are excited I want to say thank you to
Christian Unger who just grabbed a
website membership at join pakman.com
christian of course taking advantage of
the super-secret memorial 20 discount
why don't you see it up there because
it's a secret this was supposed to be a
one-day special that we did on Monday
Memorial Day but I have told you because
I like you guys so much that it the code
is still active it's Memorial 20 euro
Han
Graner rude I hope I'm not totally
butchering that has also taken advantage
of that code at join pakman.com and is
new member number two today help us
close out May on a positive note as we
have such a positive event here a taking
place just a reminder the significance
of this this would be the first time so
NASA famously is now partnering with
companies like SpaceX this is a SpaceX
Falcon 9 rocket that you see everything
down here all the way up to the tip
everything but the tip is the Falcon 9
rocket this is the dragon spacecraft it
is a NASA craft that is where the two
astronauts douglas hurley and robert
Behnken are sitting right now and have
been sitting for some time this is a
joint venture this would be the first
launch from US soil to space since 2011
in nine years it would be the first
crewed mission that SpaceX participates
in ever ever ever ever
certainly I see people very very
titillated I think we can say that this
is this is all you know these astronauts
are Giga Chad's I think is what people
mean and I've learned that that is good
that's a good thing you want to be a
Giga Chad that's a really really great
thing and we may well see that just 14
minutes from now absolutely unbelievable
amber Mourdock has grabbed a membership
at join Pakman
and his new member number three today
what a day what a day and I see people
are very very excited let's listen in
and see what else we have we're getting
very close here final minutes in
terminal count I'll take it away John -
13 minutes 30 seconds continuing to
countdown we're continuing to load Phil
onto the first stage that should finish
up in just about six minutes Wow
Phil is completely loaded on the second
stage that's closed out and we are
continuing to load liquid oxygen on both
the first and second stage the liquid
oxygen load beginning on the second
stage just about three and a half
minutes ago
we are also loading cryogenic helium
into the storage vessels on the first
and second stage getting in the last
little bits of helium when we keep it
cryogenic cold and liquefied that gets
us just like we do with liquid oxygen
the maximally incredible achievement of
engineering and science and and human
creativity
thanks to die hard for subscribing and
supporting me on Twitch also thanks to
dragonfly back home
Brett Harkness asks via YouTube super
chat David have you talked about missing
mail-in ballots apparently 1/6 of
mail-in ballots go missing each year
yeah listen so those numbers are being
presented to you in a completely biased
way to make you think that there might
be something fraudulent going on but
understand that a lot of people don't
actually fill them in we we have talked
about that it I will continue to talk
about it the issue of fraudulent vote by
mail as affecting elections is
absolutely and completely bogus
I want to say a huge thank you to
william chan who is new member number
four today at join pakman.com what an
exciting day finishing up may hopefully
starting to transition to a better time
when it comes to the global pandemic
that has been so mishandled by our
tangerine leader donald trump and folks
showing some of their support for the
david pakman show which I very very much
appreciate Luis Nodin wants to
what are my thoughts on the UK Kovan
response I don't know enough about I'm
not the person to really comment on it I
know about our response here and it's
been disgusting but I am I am less
intimately familiar with the British
British response so there are certainly
other folks I think who would be better
people to contribute there I want to say
thank you to Paul
clavier who is new member number five
Joshua McTeague is new member number six
today Kerry Riedel is new member number
seven very much appreciate your support
let's listen in as we are going now
about to go below t-minus 10 minutes
here void and so you should hear the
call out be something similar to forward
to Shannon and that just refers to
Shannon Ireland which they'll be going
off the coast of Ireland at the later
stages of the second stage if they have
to abort
so just prepping you now for some of
those calls you're hopefully gonna hear
that word nominal a whole lot on the way
uphill ten and a half minutes things are
pretty quiet as John I said it'll pick
up it right in about ten minutes we'll
wait for the crew just to confirm that
their displays are in order the crew is
already strapped in and reported that
they are go for launch
right and we'll continue to watch the
fuel gauges tick up on the Falcon 9
vehicle until fueling cuts off at just
about two minutes prior to launch dragon
SpaceX confirmed displays are a good
figure for lunch and we do now get under
the placement ten minutes our ways are
configured for launch
copy Bob Doug on behalf of the entire
SpaceX team it's been a huge honor to
help you get ready for today's historic
mission know that we're with you have an
amazing flight and enjoy those of use of
our beautiful planet I am going to
switch streams apparently we are about
20 seconds behind the space secretary
miss bastard where you are configured
for launch we are coming up on 9 minutes
and Counting
beautiful we are now we've gone through
t-minus 10 minute with the career
discussions activity is now gonna switch
over to Falcon 9 our next major event
comes at t-minus seven minutes we begin
what we call engine chill right pre
valves will open those currently
separate propellants on the first day so
we've got about a minute 45 until the
next major milestone we are still a go
for launch and only eight and a half
minutes away what an incredible day what
an incredible day thanks to Tara beard
Tara just signed up on my website using
that secret Memorial Day coupon code
memorial 20 really appreciate that so
appreciate everybody support
ekoo says via super chat hello from
Sweden so great to have folks so
watching from all over the world l'm
anta 67 and Connor Brenner have signed
up to support the show via twitch which
is extraordinarily exciting Ryan Muller
is new member number nine today at join
pakman.com what a day we can feel the
excitement it is palpable palpable
excitement we sadly had to scrub the
launch
earlier in the week at t minus 17 we are
now ten minutes past that and rapidly
approaching this first crude launched by
SpaceX ever and the first launch from US
soil in nine years last one was in 2011
thanks to Nolan Kennedy for grabbing a
membership at join pakman.com you are
number 10 let's get back as we approach
this crucial 7 minute mark and see what
the discussion is
thanks ray for the super chat as well
very much appreciate that and we are
just ten seconds from this critical
seven-minute milestone at which point
things will escalate dramatically from
what we were told
although not instant age 1 and stage 2
engine chill has started there we go
we've heard the call-out
Stage one engine chill has started
that's gone up to the crew so that
they've got situational awareness as I
mentioned the pre valves are open and
now we are topping off first stage feel
getting ready to finish the fuel load
what oxygen load up first and second
will continue until the last three to
two minutes of the countdown we should
hear that call out our p1 load complete
coming up at about six minutes again our
p1 is just that densified kerosene or
that rocket fuel that Falcon 9 is gonna
be used to power Bob and Doug to orbit
today remember our p1 and liquid oxygen
both loaded in starting at about 35
minutes prior and they don't want fuel
as both F and their stage one has been
finished loading right on time that
call-out indicates that the fuel loading
on the first stage is complete draining
back the lines now so first stage and
second stage feel our complete I mean
oxygen loading is continuing on both
stages you can see on the view on the
left side of monitor the condensation
the cold gas wrapped around the stages
is the tank skins are chilled by the
densified liquid oxygen picking up the
humidity from our Florida or Wow it
looks like at this moment we're a little
more than 90 percent full on the
oxidizer on the first age ticking up
towards that eighty percent mark on the
second stage
we'll be counting down all the way till
about two or three minutes as John I
just said until everything is London I
haters goes no thanks Connor and Chris
go for the memberships I do see those
don't want to miss the second of what
his hat rack it has transition to
configure for terminal count vehicle
tanks pressing or strong back be tracked
repressurizing the Falcon 9 tanks we're
gonna open the clamp arm around the
second-stage and begin to retract the
strong back here we go this is a major
moment critical moment we'll move back
about two degrees that'll get us to the
liftoff position ant lift off the strong
rack will then recline about 45
redressable hearted they are starting to
retract that now stage 2 RP won't bleed
launch director called out the strong
back retract has started on the left
you'll see it go back just a couple of
degrees page one are apparently
we are just four minutes away from
liftoff I got at this moment Bob and
Doug are really just laser focused on
those displays they have insight
directly into dragon in the Falcon 9
they're able to see whether fuel loading
is that being sent everything is
progressing down with the count a FPS
final set up started so as a reminder
after 2 million that half states will
separate and that first day drawing over
5,000 12 minutes from now in the next 12
minutes if all goes as planned stage 1
will propel up and come back down and
land all in the next 12 and a half
minutes if you can believe it
I'm bagging leather purses as you can
see this arm retracting
oh they'll bleed what a moment what a
moment first SpaceX Dragon has tradition
through terminal count and is on
internal power what a moment cause that
and Elon Musk
okay we're t-minus two minutes 42
seconds Stage one locks load has closed
out Stage two will continue to load for
about another half a minute or so once
we get the completion of stage two locks
loading we have to vent down the line so
you'll see another large white cloud
coming off of the strong rack that'll be
normal that'll happen with all the
transitioning one minute and 40 seconds
and of course ante vachs
I'm sorry not an Sebastian's flat
earthers whatever flat earthers are
allowed in the stream but you know that
we prefer science here since we've been
in this position a lot of work done by
thousands of people to get to this point
same thing all our eyes focused on two
now o elements of liquid on the Left
what is that page 2 lakhs flow is closed
out propellant pills are complete
dragon is an auto Idol
Stage two locks loadcomplete all fuel
all oxidizer on Falcon 9 1 minute 34
seconds to go too long what a moment
what a moment prime gas closeouts is
starting
just 70 seconds left the next ten
minutes we will see some incredible
things
Falcon 9 is a startup Braca doesn't
count down FTS is armed for lunch
things are happening under a minute now
the FTS the flight termination system
has been armed dragon SpaceX go for
launch
Wow here we go SpaceX dragon we're go
for launch let's light this candle
t-minus 30 seconds I really got to get a
close look at what's what we're seeing
here
stage 1 tanks pressing for flight
t-minus 15 seconds 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 0
[Applause]
so rise not a new era of American space
flight they fought the weapon emotions
of a new generation continuing the dream
20 seconds into flight stage 1
propulsion is nominal
P+ 30 seconds into this historic mission
flying crew up or dragon at Falcon 9 and
look at him go
Falcon pyrometry nominal
and 1d throttle down we're throttling
down to get ready for the period of
maximum dynamic pressure Wow we're in
the throttle Luckett
reports say all systems are go
vehicle is supersonic
we've exceeded Mach 1 on the Falcon 9
and one do you throttle up
we're throttling back up to full powers
we're through max Q copy one brothel
we heard that one Bravo call out the
second Ward's out that their end they'll
continue to be on this until the first
age has done its job and they switch
over to the second at this point Bob &
Doug pulling about 2.3 G's 2.3 times the
Earth's gravity already blurry at over
1,500 miles per hour we've heard the
call out for EM vac engine chill that's
giving the impact engine ready to light
that will come at about to 44 into
flight right now everything continuing
to look good next major event coming up
is going to be the triple will have main
engine cutoff of the nine first stage
engines stage separation and an ignition
of the second stage engine to continue
to carry astronauts into orbit seconds
from now I believe coming up in about 20
seconds yep
and one do you throttle down we heard
we're throttling down the merlin engines
on the first stage
and now we will see that first stage
family amico ego Falcon stage separation
confirmed there it is
[Applause]
in fact ignition alright we have stage
separation confirm the first age
beginning its flight back the second
stage being powered by that single
merlin 1d vacuum engine has ignited and
is looking like a spherical plant orbit
so they're gonna continue under the
power of this second stage propulsion is
nominal
which will cut off at Seco or second
engine cutoff at about eight minutes and
44 seconds into today's flight so a
little over five minutes to go still on
this second stage you're gonna call out
to alpha so they're now in the longest
abort zone that carries them all the way
from about North Carolina up the eastern
seaboard almost to Canada things looking
good though
getting good call-outs nominal for
propulsion on that second stage bobbin
though continuing to make their way into
orbit and that stage one rocket now
beginning its descent back to earth as
far as we believe about nine and a half
minutes basic nominal trajectory would
be when it lands that question of signal
Bermuda that dragon nominal trajectory
all right here in nominal trajectories
the dragon pointed in the right
direction continuing to make their
flight uphill hurt acquisition of signal
no Bermuda that's one of the other
ground stations that they're using to
get telemetry and data back from this
space cage to propulsion is until
nominal
for people asking they are going to the
International Space Station some folks
joining us in progress here first crewed
SpaceX launch ever burst from US soil
since 2011 four and a half minutes in
stage one rocket has already separated
little over four minutes 40 seconds into
the flight Bob & Doug flying at more
than 5,600 miles nominal trajectory
already almost 200 miles downrange from
the Kennedy Space Center nominal
trajectory continuing
and while they continue up it looks like
we are getting a view of the first age
as well yep on your right screen you can
see that first stage with the grid fins
deployed it's making its way back to
attempt to land on our drone ship of
course I still love you today we're just
about a minute a couple minutes away
from the entry burn and that's where
three of the nine Merlin engines do
ignite to help slow the vehicle down as
it re-enters back into the Earth's
atmosphere that will be a key moment
after the entry burn will be the landing
burn which is just a single engine
SpaceX nominal trajectory and you heard
nominal starting chills does that call
out they are still on a nominal
trajectory on dragon still on
second-stage and that's that em back
engine on second stage on your left
screen
again on your right screen is that first
stage booster coming back towards our
drone ship of course I still love you
we're about a minute away from entry
burn isn't this the best meanwhile that
second stage continuing to power dragon
into orbit and if you're keeping an eye
on that timer that's gonna continue to
burn until 8 minutes and 44 seconds into
flight so a little over two minutes from
now we'll hear the call-out Seco it will
then be a little too purple a little
more good a little over three minutes
until dragon physically separates from
the second stage of the Falcon 9 after
the upper trajectory but I could happen
on the trajectory continuing to check in
with Bob and Doug as they are on a
nominal trajectory just about 10 seconds
away from that first stage starting that
entry burn on your right screen we
should be able to see that view live and
I believe that it's only two minutes
from landing back down on the planet
Earth the stage 1 rocket on the right
side of course and now you start this
burn lasts about 36 seconds long
stage 2 FTS is saved
well that entry burned continues were
just about a minute away from Seco we'll
have a number of events all happen in
rapid succession the second engine
cutoff they'd want to be looking for
that stage one landing burn
shortly after passing 20,000 kilometers
per hour actually just within a few
seconds of each other it's such a cool
view on your left screen seeing Bob and
Doug on Dragon right now you can see the
displays that they are seeing right now
than central guidance and back there
also
we are coming up 25 seconds or so away
from Seco or second engine cutoff this
is also the point where Bob and Doug are
experiencing their highest g-force for
seeing the counter tick up to write
about the organic coffee Shannon you
heard Shannon so that just means they're
in their final abort zones if they were
to abort at this point but either being
abort to orbit or to land off the coast
of Ireland standing by for sighted
one-line on Florida confirmation and
back Darla step and back shut down did
rental anywhere everybody masked up good
information of Seco second engine cutoff
now we are waiting for our first stage
to make its way to our drone ship of
course I still love dragon SpaceX
nominal orbital insertion Wow
what you're seeing on your screen is a
live view of our drone ship where our
first stage will be coming down oh no
that's not good looks like we lost that
live view but wait for confirmation of
that landing shortly here we got to see
that very exciting for us and as you can
see on your right screen Bob and Doug
are still making their way to their
targeted orbits someone need a recovery
one so exciting today it doesn't stop it
does not stop all right we did we did
hear again that call-out good orbital
insertion so that means Falcon 9 and
Dragon right now exactly where they're
supposed to be and we need a FRC under
everyone and it's right at about 12
minutes or when dragon will separate
looks like we saw 0g indicator floating
around there I know Bob and Doug Oh us a
little bit about what exactly that is
that they brought up with them
and before separation before dragon
initiate separation from the second
stage they do make sure to make they do
ensure that the vehicle is not spinning
and it is in good condition before we
separate that's right the upper stage
does small attitude maneuver using cold
gas thrusters built into the rocket body
itself and I believe we do expect that
separation to occur in about a minute
from now they do wait until they have
full confirmation that it is ready to
separate such cool views I cannot get
over this view that we are seeing right
now Bob and Doug on the right screen
inside of crew dragon out I see people
in the chat yeah hitting that lammeter's
I really and that's me thinking I'll
take traveling in excess of 2700 meters
27,000 metres person I really feel bad
for you guys are about 16,000 miles per
hour
again we're just standing by that
separation event should be coming up
shortly and they'll begin a series of
checks on the Draco thrusters that are
going to be used to maneuver and then
power dragon on its flight to the
International Space Station right
standing by for separation expected
losses signal Wallops it sounds like we
had an expected
ello s lost a signal with one of the
ground stations waiting for confirmation
now and their separation confirmed their
dragon separation confirms there is a
great view right in front of you dragon
separating and there's that call out
dragon is now officially making its way
to the International Space Station today
dragon SpaceX with that separation call
we have a few words for you from our
Falcon 19
Danny Boy dragon chief engineer on
dragon to ground
Bob Doug on behalf of the entire launch
team thanks for flying with Falcon 9
today we hope you enjoyed the ride and
wish you a great mission right thanks
Paula congratulations to you and the F n
team for the first human ride for Falcon
9 and it was incredible appreciate all
the hard work and thanks for the great
rides of space Cappy oh how I like it
proud of you guys and the rest of the
team thank you so much for what you've
done for us today putting America back
into low Earth orbit up or from the
Florida coast
good luck Godspeed
all right so Bob and Doug are in a
second firm nominal eCos activation and
service section Drako checkouts nosecone
deploys in progress has Trump taking
credit for this on Twitter yet I'm not
gonna look gabion
we're monitoring the core here in
Hawthorne giving the crew a heads up
that we have confirmation the nosecone
is deploying so again that nose cone is
going to open up a little bit more than
90 degrees goes up to about I think 105
degrees and that's gonna expose the
actual docking ring and the hatch that
they're gonna be going through once they
attach to the International Space
Station and also four of those Draco
thrusters become the forward bulkhead
thrusters they're gonna be used for
these major phase burns or firings of
those trusters to actually raise their
orbit gradually over the coming hours
also heard good activation of the
Eclipse that's the environmental control
and life support system that's
everything controlling their atmosphere
just keeping dragon a nice safe
habitable environment where they're
gonna be living for the next 19 hours
until they arrive at the space station
Wow exactly and Falcon nines job may be
done for today but the mission is not
over crew dragons job is not done
as you can see Bob and Doug are still
inside crew dragon making their way it
will be a 19-hour trip to the
International Space Station before they
dock tomorrow 85 to go in such cool
views I love that we can get these live
views here and see and watch what
they're doing now that they are in orbit
it's it's incredible to just be looking
to over their shoulder to be along for
the ride and we're gonna be with them
and we're gonna be with all of you the
entire way for their journey to the
space station we're gonna be covering
live throughout Bob and Doug will
obviously have a sleep period where
they'll get about 8 hours of sleep a
little bit later today before they wake
up for all their final approach one of
the major things we are looking forward
to in the next couple of hours is gonna
be their first turn at the controls so
they're actually going to be I'm sure
it's real easy to just go to sleep for
eight hours
in the middle of that trip right elet
dragon will walk you through what that's
going to look like and assuming we have
some good ground station coverage we'll
be able to get views from right inside
dragon looking over their shoulder as
they manipulate the controls at the
display but I mean if we had a smooth
ride uphill both stages of the Falcon 9
doing their job
placing Bob and Doug in orbit I mean
this is this is a day this is a
historical day this is us kicking off
that new era of spaceflight that we've
all been talking about and longing for
since the space shuttle program came to
an end in 2011 yeah the weather the
weather cooperated yes second time's a
charm right all right so Dave for the
history book books as you can see we
have a lost some live signal there but
the mission still continues and we're
going to send it over to KSC to continue
broadcasting live with us so you know
the useful end
yeah Jesse and Dan we are just in awe
over here today woke up this morning and
looked at the weather forecast I was
like man we're gonna be back here on
Sunday but we we did it and the room
cleared out everybody was outside
watching and the and the inside the
lights were shaking the cameras were
shaking Lauren came back in with tears
guys it has happened that is going to be
it for me wanted to pop in for a rare
weekend stream because this is so so
important maybe we'll stream the docking
tomorrow with the space station really
appreciate everybody who joined me and
there will be no shortage of things to
discuss and the week upcoming I'll see
you guys soon
you